JENNA: So today, we're very
lucky to be joined with Janet
Fletcher, food writer and chef.
She's going to speak
to us about how
to make yogurt from scratch.
And then we're going to have a
delicious carrot-cumin yogurt
salad.
JANET FLETCHER: Thanks, Jenna.
Yeah, I think this is
really a great fit with what
Google is trying to do here.
Because yogurt is a
really wholesome food.
And it's never more wholesome
and fresh and natural
than when you make it yourself.
I think one of the reasons I
wrote the book about yogurt
was because I wanted
to steer people
away from what I consider
the bad choices, really,
at the supermarket.
There are so many
yogurts out there.
And a lot of them are
really not very wholesome.
They're more like pudding.
They're loaded with
a lot of sugar.
They're really
more like desserts.
And I thought if I
could steer people first
to some better choices
at the supermarket
and then maybe gradually get
them to making yogurt at home,
they really have
made a much more--
they're making much better
choices for their diet.
How many of you have
made yogurt at home?
OK, not very many.
Any of you who make it at
home make it regularly?
OK, great.
Great.
Well, I'm really glad.
Because that means there are
a lot of you who haven't.
So I'm going to be able to show
you something that, I hope,
you're going to get
hooked on like I am.
I'm never without
yogurt in my fridge.
And it's so easy.
Yogurt is really
just cultured milk.
And we're going to
start with whole milk.
This is a Straus milk,
the organic Straus
milk from West Marin.
So I like it because
it's organic.
I like it because it's local.
And I really like it
because it's whole milk.
I really am a big
advocate for-- this looks
like a delicate operation here.
JENNA: Flawless.
JANET FLETCHER: --for
whole fat dairy products.
So we have a quart of milk here.
Now, I'm going to do
a couple of things
with this yogurt recipe that
you won't see in other books,
probably, or other
online recipes.
I have a couple of approaches
that are a little different.
And here's the first one, I
add a little nonfat dry milk.
I'm going to add 2 tablespoons
of nonfat dried milk-- instant
nonfat dry milk-- to
every quart of yogurt.
This recipe is very scalable.
I could make a half gallon of
yogurt or a gallon of yogurt.
And the reason I
add this dry milk
is because it's going to
give me a thicker yogurt.
The dry milk is just
protein, no fat.
Protein and some
lactose, some milk sugar.
And it's the protein
that makes yogurt thick.
So by enhancing
the protein, I am
going to make a thicker yogurt.
So let's get this going.
I'm going to put
it on about medium.
And because it's
instant dry milk,
it'll just whisk right in.
You can also get non-instant.
But you really have to
whisk it quite a bit.
This will whisk in.
And so I'm basically
adding more protein.
And I'm going to
get a thicker yogurt
and I want to say a firmer set.
You know how some yogurts
are really very fragile
and some are thicker
and sturdier?
This nonfat dry milk is
going to help give us
a thicker and more stable set.
And--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JANET FLETCHER: Pardon me?
AUDIENCE: Would it work
with a whey protein powder?
JANET FLETCHER: It would
work with whey protein.
Yeah, I don't know why not.
I don't know why not.
I haven't tried it.
I just buy the instant dry
milk powder at the supermarket.
All I'm trying to do is
bring out the protein.
So the other thing I do--
typically, a lot of recipes
are going to tell you
to heat it to 180.
I'm going to heat it higher.
I'm going to heat
it to 190, 195.
And then I'm going to hold
it there for 10 minutes.
And the reason that
I do that-- first
of all, the reason that people
heat the milk to begin with-- I
mean, I started with
pasteurized milk.
Why do you have to heat it?
I'm heating it to get
rid of any bacteria that
might compete with my culture.
So I'm basically
re-pasteurizing it.
Because milk that's
been in the carton,
it could've been contaminated
after pasteurization.
It's just a safety measure
to bring the milk up
to a high temperature to
kill any bacteria that
might compete with your
culture, the bacteria
that you want to grow.
But by bringing it
up to 190 or 195
and then holding it
there for 10 minutes,
I'm doing a couple of things.
I'm concentrating the
milk a little bit.
Because, you'll see, there's
a lot of evaporation.
But most importantly,
I'm denaturing
one of the whey proteins--
the lactoglobulin.
And by the heat and that
10 minutes at 190 or 195
denatures the whey
protein lactoglobulin.
And so then that
whey protein can
get caught up in the yogurt.
And I'm going to get, again, a
thicker and more stable yogurt.
These are two
techniques-- the dry milk
and the extra heating--
that really work.
You don't have to do them.
You're still going
to get yogurt.
But you're going to get a
more fragile yogurt and one
that's not quite as thick.
So I think they really help
produce the kind of yogurt
that I like, which
is thick and creamy.
You can use any kind
of milk for yogurt.
You can use nonfat,
low fat, full fat.
I advocate full fat not
only because it gives you
more mouth feel
and more pleasure,
but because, really, when
you think about it, if you're
going to use a nonfat
milk to make your yogurt,
you are saving so few calories.
A lot of the recipes
in the book have
maybe a cup of yogurt in them.
And they serve four people.
So on a per serving
basis, the difference
between using a nonfat
yogurt and a full fat yogurt
is about 20 calories.
And the flavor and texture
difference is noticeable.
So I really advocate
the whole milk yogurt.
Everything's going to
taste better with it.
All the recipes will work with
low fat yogurt in the book.
But they're going to taste a
lot better with full fat yogurt.
What do you use when
you make your yogurt?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JANET FLETCHER: And it failed?
OK, well, after
today you won't fail.
Yogurt really is a
no-fail procedure
if you pay attention
to a few things.
What is yogurt, after all?
It's cultured milk.
It's milk that we add
a selected culture to
in order to ferment the
milk sugar, the lactose.
These bacterial cultures
love the lactose.
They're going to eat it
up and create lactic acid.
And the lactic acid is
going to lower the pH.
It's going to raise the acidity.
And that's going to
cause our fermentation.
It's a lot like making
cheese, except the bacteria
are different.
And when you think about it,
yogurt, the first yogurt,
certainly, was just
a spontaneous thing.
It just happened with
the ambient bacteria
and some shepherd's milk.
And over time,
over centuries, we
figured out what
bacteria do the best
job, which ones are reliable
and give the best flavor.
So today-- I'm just going
to check the temperature.
I want to bring it up to 190.
This is called a Thermapen.
You can just use any kind
of instant-read thermometer.
But this is like the Mercedes
of instant-read thermometers.
And it's great.
Do you have one, Deedee?
I love--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JANET FLETCHER: Yeah,
you want a Thermapen.
So we're at about 165.
So we've got a ways to go.
It's going to be
almost to boiling.
So it's going to give us
a lot of foam on the top.
The original yogurt
was just milk
that fermented from
the ambient bacteria.
But now we choose the
bacteria that we want to add.
And all yogurt, by FDA
definition-- or maybe
it's the USDA that
regulates those things.
The federal
definition for yogurt,
there are two bacteria
that it has to have.
One would be the
Lactobacillus bulgaricus.
And the other is
Streptococcus thermophilus.
But if you look at
a carton of yogurt,
you're going to see, probably,
some other Latin on there,
some other bacteria listed.
And those are there
for probiotic benefit.
Things like Lactobacillus
acidophilus, that's not there
to really culture the milk.
It's there for the
probiotic benefit.
So when you're
making yogurt, you
have to have-- you can
use three different things
for your culture.
You can use your
own homemade yogurt
from the batch you
just made last week.
You can use a
store-bought yogurt.
Or you can use a freeze-dried
culture you can find online.
And in some cheese
making supply shops,
there are freeze-dried cultures,
which are kind of nice to use.
Because you can just
put them in the freezer.
And they keep forever.
But I usually use
either a couple
of tablespoons from my
last batch of yogurt
or just a freshly opened
container of yogurt.
Let's see where we are.
We are getting real close.
We're at 190.
So at this point, I'm going
to turn it down to low.
On my home stove, I
just turn it to low
and leave it for 10 minutes.
And again, that's to
denature this whey protein.
And then we will cool
it really quickly.
So I'm going to
need an ice bath.
Because what we could
do once it reaches
that-- can somebody
just let me know
when 10 minutes have passed?
OK.
At that point, I could just
put it aside and cool it down
naturally to my
culturing temperature.
But I'm going to try to
speed things up and do it
in an ice bath.
And if I just put it
aside, it would take, oh,
45 minutes, probably,
to come down
to the culturing temperature.
In an ice bath, it
takes three minutes.
So the culturing temperature
is the temperature
that the bacteria like.
Everything is about
keeping the bacteria happy.
Because they're our labor force.
They're what's going to make
the fermentation happen.
And they like a little
heat, but not too much.
Too much heat will kill them.
Too cold, they won't
work fast enough.
So the target
range for your milk
when you add the bacteria
is about 108 to 118.
If you go above
118, you'll probably
kill your bacteria culture.
Below 108 or 105,
and the culture
really gets off to
a sluggish start.
So we don't want that to happen.
So after I put it
in the ice bath,
I'm going to monitor it and try
to get it at that 108 to 118
range.
And that's when we'll
add our culture.
In the meantime, I'm going
to make a very quick yogurt
dish for you.
One of the reasons that I
wrote the book, in addition
to trying to steer
people to better choices
and teach them how
to make their own,
was that I wanted to
invite people to experience
the savory side of yogurt.
How many of you eat yogurt?
Let me ask that.
OK, a lot of you.
I'm going to guess that most of
you eat yogurt for breakfast.
Or you have it with honey or
fruit or sugar, brown sugar,
in a sweet way.
You tend to have it as
a sweet, as a breakfast
or as a sweet snack.
There are so many wonderful
savory ways to enjoy yogurt.
And I've learned about
them not from growing up
with them, but from,
as a food writer,
exploring other cultures--
Indian, especially in North
India-- major yogurt territory--
the Middle East, the Balkans,
Greece, and Turkey.
These are all places where
yogurt is always on the menu,
always on the table.
And yogurt can really
help introduce you
to some of these other cultures.
So this is a savory dish.
This is a salad.
that I'm going to make
with a little olive oil.
I'm going to just heat these
carrots, grated carrots, that I
grated on this coarse
side of the box
grater, these coarse holes.
That's what I used to
grate the peeled carrots.
You can grate them ahead.
And I'm just going to switch
them in this hot olive oil.
I want the pan to be pretty hot.
And I'm not trying
to fully cook them.
I just want to wilt
them until they
lose some of their crispness.
I'm going to salt them.
And I'm going to toss
them just until they
lose a little crispness.
And then I'm going to put them
into some flavored yogurt.
So what I'm going
to put them into
is a mix of yogurt,
garlic, and toasted cumin--
just some whole milk
yogurt-- it doesn't
have to be Greek
yogurt-- yogurt that I've
added some chopped garlic
to and some toasted cumin.
And let's see.
If we have time, I'll show you
how I do the toasted cumin.
So just a couple
minutes does it.
I can smell that wonderful
smell of the carrots coming up.
And I'm going to turn
it off now and just
let it sit in that pan.
And we will toast
some cumin quickly.
All spices are so much
better when they're toasted.
This is just cumin
straight out of the jar.
And if you toast it, you have
a totally different experience.
Suddenly, you have cumin.
You have the smell of
Mexico, the smell of India.
It's nothing until you toast it.
And you do it just in a
dry skillet-- no olive oil,
nothing.
And so I take it probably
farther than a lot of people.
I like it to get really
almost dark brown.
And then I'm going to
pound it in a mortar.
If you have a spice grinder
or a dedicated coffee grinder
or even a coffee
grinder that you're
willing to really
clean out well,
then you can use your cumin.
You don't want your coffee
smelling like cumin.
So it's good to have
a dedicated grinder.
I'm a real believer in
doing stuff by hand.
So I have a whole mortar
collection at home.
I just love the pounding.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JANET FLETCHER: I'm starting
with the seeds, yeah.
You could do store-bought,
ground cumin.
But the point is really
to start with the seeds.
The seeds almost never go
stale in your spice drawer.
The powder, once it's ground,
it has a very short life
before it loses its aroma, like
a matter of a couple of months,
really, before you lose a lot.
Whereas the seeds you
can keep for a year.
So I always buy my spices
whole and then toast them.
I'm already getting
some aroma up here.
And then we'll
grind them and we'll
add it to-- this is just
some plain whole milk yogurt.
OK, I can smell it.
And I'm going to
add some garlic.
Do we have a microplane?
I'm going to grate my garlic.
Thank you.
This is a microplane.
I can't live without this now.
And I'm going to stop that.
I might go a little
further at home.
But I'm just going
to stop that for now.
And I'm going to grate
some garlic into here.
If you drop the
garlic, no big deal.
Just reach in there
and pick it up.
And I'm going to whisk
in a little bit of salt.
Even though I put some
salt in my carrots,
I know I'll need a
little more there.
Thank you.
And I'm going to pound
that-- let's put this out
of the way for now.
I'm going to pound the cumin.
If you're going to buy
a mortar, buy a big one.
You can always do a small
job in a big mortar.
But you can't do a big
job in a small one.
So buy more capacity than
you think you might need.
Asian markets have
a wonderful mortar.
It's a mortar that's very
much used in the Thai kitchen.
And it's kind of like
this, but a little bigger.
And they're very inexpensive.
And you'll have it for life.
So see how quickly
that ground up?
And I'm now going to
put that into my yogurt.
And my carrots are hot.
I don't want to add anything
really hot to the yogurt
because I might break it.
But I think they've
probably cooled off
enough now that I can add them.
But yogurt's not
like sour cream.
You can't subject
it to direct heat.
You have to kind of
temper it by adding
something that's warm to it
to bring it up to temperature.
So we've got salt, garlic,
and toasted cumin in here.
And now I'm going
to add my carrots.
And probably wouldn't have hurt
to cool them a little bit more.
But I don't think
we're going to break.
And I'm going to add
the herb of choice
You could use dill if you like.
We're going to
use some cilantro.
You could use mint.
You could use just
parsley if you
don't like any of those others.
But I like cilantro in here.
And I'm just going to chop
some cilantro and put that in.
And then do we have a nice
plate we can put it on?
Thank you.
She's one step ahead of me.
A little lemon juice,
usually, I add to taste.
Thank you.
I'm going to chop
some cilantro here.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JANET FLETCHER: OK.
[BEEPING]
Is that telling me
something, that buzzer?
JENNA: It's the
timer for the stove.
JANET FLETCHER: So is that
the 10 minutes for our yogurt?
OK.
Oh, that's what you meant.
All right.
So I'm going to turn that
off or just move it aside.
Because we don't need
to cook it any more.
And we'll get this, hold it in.
As I said, you can
use another herb
if you prefer if you're
not a cilantro person.
I've also made this
salad with beets.
It's delicious with
beets-- cooked beets.
I don't usually do the beets
sauteed on top of the stove.
I just roast them
and then grate them
and fold them into the yogurt.
The wonderful thing you start
to notice when you play around
with yogurt and look
at yogurt recipes
is that there's such
a yogurt trail that
extends from where
yogurt originated
in Central Asia, like
Afghanistan and Iran and then--
well, from Afghanistan into
Iran, then down into India
it traveled.
And then it traveled
west to the Balkans.
And in all these places, they
make a lot of the same dishes.
They just vary the seasoning.
So for example, an
Indian would probably
recognize this is very similar
to a raita, a yogurt salad
in India.
It usually has maybe a little
more yogurt and less vegetable.
This is a Turkish salad.
But in India,
you're going to have
more yogurt and less vegetable.
But that would be a
raita, or a yogurt salad.
In Greece-- tzatziki,
the cucumber
salad that they make
in much the same way.
So same salad, same
concept, but so
many variations on it that
are really fun to discover.
So now with our
yogurt, we've cooked it
for 10 minutes at 190.
Now I'm going to put it in
this ice bath over here.
We don't need quite
this much ice.
OK.
And we'll see how fast this is.
I don't think it's
going to-- it's not
going to take five minutes.
My guess is more
like three minutes
to bring it down to--
what did I say, 108?
But I usually go
115 when I culture.
So let's clean up a little bit.
Normally, at home, I
wouldn't have anything else
going on when I'm making yogurt.
Because you want to
keep pretty clean.
You don't want to get any
other bacteria involved
other than the
ones that you want.
So you should have clean
jars, clean towels,
clean implements of all kinds.
This is what I'm
going to incubate in.
You could incubate
it in anything.
You could incubate it in a bowl.
You don't have to have a jar.
Some people use just
preserving jars, mason jars.
But a bowl is fine.
JENNA: Do you sanitize your
jars the way you would for--
JANET FLETCHER: Yeah,
I do, absolutely.
I wash them with
hot, soapy water.
And then often, I'll just
keep hot water in them
until I'm ready to fill
them so that they stay warm.
Because now we let
it get down to 115.
But then after we
add the culture,
we really want to baby it.
We want to keep it warm.
You have to keep that
culture about 105 to 115
to keep the yogurt-- to
keep it working for you.
JENNA: For how long?
JANET FLETCHER:
Until it sets, which
can be anywhere from
three hours to 12 hours.
It depends how
active your culture
is, how warm you're keeping it.
This clicked off on me.
Let me just shut it down.
And then it will
come right back up.
Do you have that proofer
box that I can show people?
You need nothing to
make yogurt at home.
You don't need this.
In the old days, the
grandmas would just
put the milk on
their wrists and see.
And they knew whether
it was warm enough.
And they could judge
whether it was warm enough
to add their culture.
But this makes it a lot
more precise, a thermometer.
And you don't need
anything special
for your incubating environment.
A lot of people will do it in
an oven with the pilot light on.
I do it sometimes just
on my kitchen island.
I'll put a blanket down.
And I'll put blankets
around the jars.
I'm trying to keep it
at that 105 to 115,
anyway you can come
up with to do it.
Some people put it
in a picnic cooler
that they've put maybe
some warm water in.
So they just put it in a
warm spot in their house.
And just check to
make sure you're
keeping it in that
incubation zone.
OK.
We are already down to--
we're down there to 108.
So that didn't take
long in the ice bath.
And now I'm ready
to add my culture.
And as we said-- oh, I got a
little parsley in my culture.
Does somebody have a
plastic spoon maybe?
I've got a little
cilantro my culture.
JENNA: So Janet, if
you're down to 108,
are you concerned with
bringing it back up?
JANET FLETCHER: No.
If you do go too
low, not a problem.
Just put it back on the stove.
until you get it back
to that 108 to 118 zone.
So this is, as I
said, we could use--
this is store-bought yogurt.
But it could've been yogurt
from a previous batch.
I'm just going to thin
it out a little bit.
It would be nice to have--
we'll see if I can do it
with this little whisk.
It would be nice to have
a bigger glass bowl.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JANET FLETCHER: Yeah,
that'll work if it's cleans.
OK, yeah.
So I'm going to put
my culture in here.
And I'm going to add some of
the warm milk to the culture
just to temper it and
thin it out a little bit.
And then we'll whisk
it back in to the milk.
I'm just trying to
warm it up gently
and thin it out so it will
mix well with the milk.
And now I'll put it
back into the milk
that I know is not too
hot, make sure it's
well-distributed with my whisk.
And that's your culturing.
That's all that culturing is,
is adding that bacteria that
are in the yogurt.
So if you're going to use a
store-bought yogurt to culture,
you have to make sure that
it says on the package,
contains live, active cultures.
Otherwise, you
can't make yogurt.
And believe it or not, there
are some yogurts out there
that do not have
live, active cultures.
They tend to be the
mass market brands.
And the reason they don't
have live, active cultures
is because they pasteurized
the yogurt after they made it.
to give it shelf stability.
You don't want that.
It's not going to make yogurt.
And it doesn't have
any probiotic benefit.
That's one of the reasons
for eating yogurt.
So be sure you look
at the container
and look for that phrase,
live, active cultures.
And then you know you're
getting some probiotic benefit.
And you can use it
to make your own.
So more culture isn't better.
A lot of people
might think that.
That was 2 tablespoons of
yogurt per quart of milk.
More culture isn't going
to culture it faster.
And it's not going to
give you a thicker yogurt.
In fact, it can
work against you.
Because it can
overwhelm the bacteria.
There may not be enough
bacteria for all the sugar.
Or, excuse me, the other
way around-- enough sugar
for all the bacteria.
So I'm just going to start off.
I'm only doing this slowly
so I don't make a mess.
But once I get it
about halfway in there,
I will just pour it in.
And at this point comes
what's our fermentation phase,
culturing phase.
And that's when we really
want to make sure that we
are keeping it around 105, 115.
And I'll show you this
device that I use at home
and have come to love.
You're going to want
to have a lid on it.
And so at this
point, I would either
put it on my kitchen
island with towels over it,
towels around it.
It's like a heap of blankets
on my kitchen counter.
And after about four
hours, I'll come check it.
And you don't want to move
it while it's fermenting.
It doesn't want to be jostled.
So if I think, well, it's been
four hours, maybe it's done,
I'll come undo my blankets.
And I'll undo the clamps.
And I just jostle
it a little bit.
And I'm looking to see whether
it's like a baked custard.
I don't want it
to be still soupy.
It needs to be set
like a custard.
And I find on my kitchen
counter about four hours.
But with this
device, which I only
learned about when I was
researching my book--
and I was reading people
online describing it.
And it sounded kind of cool.
So I contacted the company.
And they sent me a loaner.
And I'm very happy that they
haven't asked for their loaner
back.
Because I love this thing.
It started out as
a bread proofer.
That's how they invented it.
The name of the company
is Brod &Taylor.
I think it's a very small
appliance manufacturer.
And they invented it to
proof bread for home bakers.
But somebody along the line
decided to try it for yogurt.
And it works great for yogurt.
It's an electric device.
And the thing that's
so great about it
compared to a lot of
electric yogurt makers
is that it has a thermostat
that you can set.
So I can dial it to 108 degrees,
which is where I do yogurt.
It makes yogurt in three hours--
totally steady, 108 degrees.
My husband uses it for
his bread at 80 degrees.
I crank it up for my yogurt.
And then it collapses down.
The sides come down.
And it folds up.
And it's easy to store.
So it's absolutely
not essential.
But it's a nice tool
to have if you're
going to make a lot of yogurt.
Because it makes it
so easy and reliably.
You never have to worry
about whether you're
keeping it warm enough.
But there are just lots of ways
you can keep the yogurt warm
at home that I've heard about.
Some people use an
electric heating pad.
Some people use a crock pot.
They'll actually warm
their milk in the crock
pot for their yogurt and
then not use their yogurt
for their incubation-- use the
crock pot for their incubation,
as well.
But I'm a big fan of just
the blanket method if I'm not
going to use this device.
So after, say, four
hours, you check it.
You find that it's set.
If it's not set,
just keep going.
Put your blankets back.
Or put it back in your
oven with the pilot light.
Keep going.
Check it in another hour.
When you've decided
that it's set,
then it needs to go
into the refrigerator.
It's kind of tempting
to scoop into it.
But I think it's much better
if it sets up in the fridge
and really gets its
nice firmness to it
before you try to use it.
Then if you want to make
Greek yogurt-- super easy.
After you've chilled it down,
then you need to strain it.
That's all Greek yogurt is.
It's just regular
yogurt that's been
strained to make it thicker.
So you would take a
colander or a sieve
and line it with-- a lot
of people use cheese cloth,
like a double or triple
thickness of cheese cloth.
Oh, I forgot to bring my Plyban.
But I have this
material that I mention
in the book called Plyban.
You get it from cheese
making supply companies.
It's a woven nylon, I think.
And compared to cheese cloth,
it lasts virtually forever.
Cheese cloth you can reuse
maybe two or three times.
The Plyban-- I've had a piece
of Plyban for three years now.
And I'm still using it.
You can wash it, clean
it, and reuse it.
So it's a great liner for
your sieve or colander.
You dump your yogurt
into that, set it
over a bowl in the refrigerator.
I usually put a
plate on top just so
that it doesn't absorb
any refrigerator smells.
And within an hour,
you have Greek yogurt.
You've drained out enough whey
to have a nice, thick yogurt
that is comparable to what
you would buy as Greek yogurt.
And that brings up another
reason to make yogurt at home--
you save a lot of money.
A quart of milk becomes
a quart of yogurt.
And if you look at the
price of a quart of milk
versus the price of
a quart of yogurt,
you're going to realize
that you're saving a lot.
So if you get in the habit
of eating a lot of yogurt
or cooking with a
lot of yogurt, you're
going to save a lot
by making your own.
But also, you can make
it with a type of milk
you like, with organic
milk if you like.
And even better, when
you're ready to eat it,
you can sweeten
it to your taste.
You can put the fresh
fruit into it, instead
of the processed fruit that
the commercial producers use.
So you're in control.
And you're going to just have
a much more wholesome and tasty
product.
And just another
point to make is
that if you're going to use a
store-bought yogurt to culture,
use a yogurt that you love.
Play the field and
find the yogurt
that you like their texture,
you like their flavor.
Some are tangier than others.
Some are mellower than others.
That flavor's going to
transfer to your yogurt because
of the bacteria that they used.
So I really like
the Straus yogurt,
the Straus organic yogurt.
It's very mellow.
It's not super tangy.
And so if I'm going to use a
store-bought yogurt to culture,
I'll use the Straus.
It gives me a more
mellow result.
I know you have questions.
AUDIENCE: So with
homemade yogurt,
how long can you keep
it in the fridge?
Because us being at Google we
eat a lot of our meals here.
And I tend to have a lot of food
that tends to sit in my fridge
for longer than it
probably should.
So what is a good estimate
of how long it can sit?
JANET FLETCHER: The
thing about yogurt
is that it's a way
of preserving milk.
That's, I think, why it
was so valued historically.
Because milk didn't last.
Yogurt lasts longer.
Greek yogurt, or drained
yogurt, lasts even longer.
It's like a dry, hard cheese
lasts longer than a moist one
because you've got
some of the whey out.
So a thick yogurt
that you've drained
is going to last
a little longer.
I would say just a plain yogurt,
like this is going to make,
would last, oh, at
least a couple of weeks.
And it's not going to go "bad."
It's not going to
get fuzzy mold on it.
It's going to start to taste
really tangy, just probably
more tangy than you like.
But if you take that extra step
of draining some of the whey
out for about an hour, I
would say even three weeks
without any change to it that
you're going to perceive.
So I make two of
these at a time.
But this is just a quart.
You know, a cup of milk and a
cup of yogurt for breakfast,
you're done in four days.
AUDIENCE: What are your thoughts
on the electric yogurt makers
that just hold the constant
temperature, as opposed
to this one, where you can vary?
JANET FLETCHER: Yeah,
they're very useful.
That's how I started many
years ago making yogurt, was
when the little five-cup
yogurt makers-- there
are five cups in them, but the
cups don't even hold a cup.
They're like six ounces,
or even less-- 5 ounces.
So you're not making a whole
lot of yogurt at a time.
But they're reliable.
Like this device, they
determined what that culturing
temperature should be.
And they hold it steady.
This one's just a
little more versatile
because you can use it
for things besides yogurt
and because I know
I like that 108.
That, for me, is my
magic hot button.
And with most of
the yogurt makers,
you don't have that
capability of setting
the temperature where you want.
They've preset it.
But to me, the biggest drawback
is they don't make very much.
But yeah, if it's something
that gets you going,
it's a good investment.
There are yogurt makers
out there for $35.
This is probably $135.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JANET FLETCHER: Yeah, great
question about the whey.
This yogurt has
everything in it.
The whey comes
about when I strain
it to make Greek yogurt
or a thicker yogurt.
The whey is what drains
out through the bottom
through that cheese
cloth or Plyban.
And it actually still does
have some nutrition in it.
A lot of people will
drink it like buttermilk.
It's tangy.
It's kind of like a thin kiefer.
So it's tangy and tart.
But it is a very
healthy beverage.
Other people put it in soups
to add some more protein
and nutrition, instead
of just adding water
to a soup or a broth.
I've used it as a
marinade for meats.
Because it still has
some milk sugar in it,
it's going to give
you more coloring,
like on a chicken
or a lamb roast.
To use it for your
marinade, you're
going to get a browner result.
And I've also heard that it's
a great hair conditioner.
But I have yet to try that.
The old timers will never
throw away the whey.
They use it, usually,
as a beverage.
This salad that you're
having, the carrot salad,
it's a nice little
kind of mezze.
If you're serving Middle
Eastern appetizers,
add some feta cheese,
add some Kalamata olives,
maybe just some crisp
cucumbers and some pita bread
or a flat bread.
It's fun to kind of
roll up in a lavash.
It's just a nice first course.
Or you can have it as a side
dish with lamb or with chicken
or with just some rice as
part of a meatless meal.
And think about the variations.
There are lots of
variations in the book.
You can use grated
zucchini, instead of
the carrots, the grated,
cooked beets that I mentioned.
You can use golden beets.
That's really pretty.
And I do one with radishes,
just grated radishes.
I don't know if you've
seen those watermelon
radishes that some of the stores
have now that are pink inside.
That makes a beautiful sort of
[INAUDIBLE] yogurt salad, just
the grated watermelon radishes,
a little bit of garlic,
a little parsley.
Really simple
salads with yogurt.
And also in the book,
I would encourage you,
for those of you
who bought the book,
to look at some of the soups.
There are not only
some cold soups
that you can make in the
blender in about five minutes,
but there are some wonderful
hot soups where you whisk yogurt
into like a base of chick peas
and chicken broth and pasta.
And it just gives a nice, creamy
richness and tang at the end.
So just so many savory
ways to use yogurt.
But I hope you'll explore.
AUDIENCE: If I could just
switch topics for a second--
I know you write a column
for "The Chronicle."
And you've written
about 500 books.
[LAUGHS] And I know that you
do a lot of food testing, too.
I'm curious if you--
just looking ahead
into the future in the
next 10, 15 years--
have a sense of just
some interesting food
trends you see coming up?
JANET FLETCHER: Well, I
think the DIY trend is huge.
And I hope it lasts.
I think it will.
Because I think once
you've made things yourself
like yogurt at home or
jam at home or pickles,
you realize how much better
it is than what you can buy.
And it's such a
satisfying thing.
So I think this concept of the
homemade will stay with us.
Certainly, I think the locavore
movement is staying with us.
I think it's
enlightened a lot of us
about how important it is
to preserve small farms,
to support small
farms in our vicinity,
to have a low carbon
footprint, and to eat locally.
And we're lucky in California.
Because there's no sacrifice
involved in eating locally.
It's so easy to do.
Gardening has become
huge in recent years.
And I hope that that's going
to stick with a lot of people.
I'm a certified master gardener.
I'm a great advocate for
just the satisfaction
of gardening at home.
You can garden in containers.
You can grow an amazing amount
of vegetables in containers,
even just some herbs.
It's such a pleasure to go
out and harvest your own herbs
from a container on
your patio or your deck.
But I do think that home
gardening, home vegetable
gardening, is going to be with
us in a big way in the future.
Because a lot of people
are concerned about what
they buy at the supermarket.
They're concerned about
what they feed their kids.
And the way to allay that
concern is to grow it yourself.
JENNA: Liv, did you
have a question?
AUDIENCE: Hi, Janet.
Two questions-- do you do yogurt
with goat milk, other milks?
Maybe some people here
may be interested even
in soy milk and coconut.
And the second
question is, then do
you take your yogurt beyond
the Greek yogurt phase
and make yogurt cheese
and other dairy products?
JANET FLETCHER: Great question.
Yeah, actually, the
picture on the cover
is a yogurt cheese, which is
just straining it further.
As I said, for about
an hour, you're
going to get Greek yogurt.
If you go for, say, 24
hours in the refrigerator,
you're going to get
something that's
spreadable like a chevre,
like fresh chevre.
And that's what some
people call yogurt cheese.
In the Middle East,
it's called labneh.
And that will keep
for a month or more
because you've
taken more whey out.
So you can put herbs on top
of that or fold them in.
You can put toasted
pumpkin seeds
or toasted sesame seeds
on top, a little olive
oil, some garlic.
It makes a great cheese spread.
So yeah, I love yogurt cheese.
And as far as different
types of milk,
you can certainly use
goat's milk, sheep's milk
if you're lucky enough to
get any, or cow's milk.
Soy milk I've never played with.
And I don't see
how it would work.
Because the bacteria
that you use to culture
milk are going
after the lactose.
And soy milk doesn't
have any lactose.
So I don't know.
You might have to find some
other way to culture it.
But goat's milk is going to
work great with the method
that I describe.
The only difference
is that goat's milk,
the structure of
it is different.
And it's more fragile.
It makes a more fragile curd.
So I really would encourage
you to use the dry milk
technique with goat's milk.
In fact, you'll see--
here's another little thing
I want to point out.
When you look at a
yogurt container,
not only do you want to have
the live, active cultures,
but the thing I avoid is
any of the stabilizers.
A lot of them have carrageenan,
gelatin, tapioca starch,
cornstarch, all of
which are food-safe.
They're fine.
But they give the
yogurt a texture
that's not what I would
consider authentic.
They make it more pudding-like
or more stiff and jelly-like.
So I always look
for a yogurt that
doesn't have any of these
stabilizers-- the starches
or gelatin-- in them.
They're getting harder to find.
But Straus, for example, does
make a plain, whole milk yogurt
without any stabilizers.
But if you're going to
buy goat's milk yogurt,
it's almost certainly going
to have a stabilizer in it
because the goat's
milk is so fragile.
They just have to do
it, or it won't travel.
But goat's milk
makes great yogurt.
And I know a lot of people
who can't tolerate cow's milk
will find the goat's
milk very digestible.
A lot of people who
are lactose intolerant
find that they can enjoy
yogurt, whereas they
can't tolerate milk.
They can tolerate yogurt
because even though it still
has some lactose, it tends
to have less typically.
So that's something-- if you're
lactose intolerant or have
friends who are,
try a little yogurt
and see if you can digest that.
JENNA: Well, thank you
so much for joining us.
JANET FLETCHER: Thank you.
It's been a pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.